so we will finish the workshop on the
same topic as we started would be finite
nominal monoids and by Thomas Cole come
back from you idiot oh yes I did not put
it so yes this is the last talk of this
wonderful workshop so I think everybody
will remember this week for many reasons
but one is that this is a this was a
wonderful scientific quick and and also
i take the occasion to to thank the
organizer of the program because this is
all these monsters are very very
productive and very interesting so those
who have the chance to be here have a
lot of chance thank you very much so
this talk is about indeed the nominal
mono it's so it refers to the road talks
we had register automata we had these
atoms when the cs peas and we are this
programming this morning it's also in
connection with characterization of
logical classes by algebraic means like
in in the talk of howard also at the
beginning of you so what what are the
two key CRMs that we have in regular
languages and that we use as a kind of
yardstick for understanding things and
for knowing what we we have in different
class of languages well so that's what i
call the fundamental theorem of regular
language everything is equivalent
magnetic second-order logic
recognizability by mano a deterministic
automata and everybody knows like a long
never-ending list of such things and
there is the second part which is
essentially story the shoots engage a
wizard then this mac naughton puppet
result which says that if you
furthermore restrict yourselves so the
money is to be a periodic then the logic
to be first order then you have well
your other models then against you have
perfect equivalent and and for for those
who were
with automata this is a kind of thing we
look at if we have a new model of things
what do we have among this video so
plain plenty of classes so if you extend
the models like 20 make hours or even
better two words of countable length you
may wonder about having exactly the same
kind of equivalences if you go to trees
you can also try to do that that works a
little that's good but ok or cost
functions you can do you can do similar
things and what we do here is try to do
this for a nominal ones for the nominal
world so now we are not talking about it
still finite words but now the words
have values that belong to some infinite
universes that as our names or integer
whatever you call them and we want to
see if we can recover part of these
results okay so what is the story of
that regular that are languages so this
this notion of data is the name that is
given I think in the database community
so so the idea is to typically encode
identifiers so imagine you have a word
and this word has a list of is a list of
things and for instance there are books
and you want to know where they are so a
basic the basic relation that you want
between two pieces of data is only the
Equality you will not compare things for
any other thing so that's why you try to
model and it has many applications or
names programming in semantics of
programming languages you can well you
can do many things with that so but for
us we have a set d of that ass or a of
atoms or n of natural numbers whatever
and we can only compare them toward
equality and when we talk about the word
essentially this all the example will be
like that sometime we can add a finite
part to its bit that's very
so how can we define devices for
recognizing language of such objects
well they were first proposal was the
one of Kaminsky unconscious which is you
add registers to your automata and these
registers can store this value if you
are finitely many of them and when you
advance in the word you can pick the
value compared with the registers you
have decided to keep it throw it away
and you go on like that till the end but
when you go in this direction you
suddenly discover that the world is not
so nice even if this model looks like
the simplest you can imagine then
deterministic is not the same as non
deterministic and invent there are
several version of non deterministic
it's also different of being mono it
it's also different to be alternating is
different but everything is different
nobody work nothing works and even worse
if you want to solve the basic questions
that usually are decidable for languages
so typically emptiness or our
universality then you turn out to be
very quickly undecidable so this is the
case if you take a non-deterministic
register automata in this sense actually
register then universality is not
decidable if you want to definitely
decide the satisfiability of first-order
logic I will talk about what are these
logic it is also and decided so things
do not look to start very well for
having a strong result where two things
would be equal oh yeah so I miss they
are still nevertheless think some things
that are decidable but for classes like
like the logic first order you know that
it's decidable only when it has two
variables and and in any case what we
can conclude is that it cannot all these
decidable case cannot be understood as
notion of regular languages which is of
course if i mean fo two if you look when
there is no data this does not look like
a regular language it's extremely weak
so can we do better than that so this is
our result and i will take most of the
time to try to explain what's going on
there
but so what is important is that it's a
it's an on the left side we have a logic
which is a magnetic second-order logic
plus some rigidity thing and so if we
use it over normal words this is full
magnetic logically completely
syntactically so we did not throw away
anything from normal logic and on the
right side we have an algebraic object
which is the one of a nominal orbit
finite moderate and we have this a
periodic version if you take exactly the
same rigid thing and you combine it with
first-order logic then you get the a
periodic fragment of the nominal Madrid
so we have something that looks so the
way to pay i think is missing yes yes
this is a periodic yeah sorry well I met
copy and past so it will be missing a
lot of time in this talk so first
question what our orbit finite nominal
mono is well we've seen so many things
during this workshop I think there is no
problem but i will just like recap some
things we have this set d of that asked
with that we can only compare to what
equality so what is that and we work
with this nominal sets so we have the
permutation of these datas that act on
all the sets i will be talking about
there is also this very important
support assumption that they will not
mention here and typical example are
like this set of that as of the square
of the set of that has a world or finite
set and when I say said I mean that the
permutation of the datas do not act on
it it's like a normal set no no that as
it then you have this notion of orbit
finite nests which is that there are
only finitely many live other sets that
have only finitely many object up to
permutation and so typically finite set
all these are but
words are not and words we care about of
course and we have the notion of being
equivalent which is like being
environmental discrimination all this is
the same so now what do we do is that
well we just take the normal definition
of a mono it but we instantiate it in
this universe in the category of nominal
set so we have this no set it's a here
but it's like the datas that we use and
as an alphabet then we have a mono it
which is like a normal manner it bit the
only thing is that instead of being
finite its orbit finite and the product
has to be equivalent and we have a
morphism from the words to this mono it
and this more freedom needs also to be
equivalent so all this is insensitive to
any particular value and we have a
finite subset of the monoid which is
also equivalent which is the set of
accepting element and we knew we have
these pieces of three element amana read
the morph is Amanda subset we can talk
about the language of data words words
over this alphabet recognized by it as
in the usual way those words such that
the image by the morph isn't belong to F
side is a little web show that in each
yeah yeah
sorry for that so here comes some
examples so usually the example due to
only talk about the the data part of it
so this for take the first example says
oh my word has its first and last values
that appear equal so we can do this by
am annoyed and this mono it is like so
we have the one this is the one of the
money the value of the empty word we
have no choice about it and then it's
disc where so I'm saying that it has
three orbits because if we look
carefully at it there is the diagonal
which acts as a different orbit but we
don't care about that and essentially
when we have a we have a word you we
want our mafia to send it to the pair of
its first value and last value okay so
and we need this should be a morphism of
mono and so of course if I take and make
the product of a web that starts with a
DN end with an e with a word that starts
with adi prime and end with an e prime i
don't care about what r and d prime i
just throw them away and i'm just saying
i get a word that starts with adi and
ends with an e prime so the more film
stars from the letter all that ID and
then by product you you get to have this
muff ism this is in part and then we
accept those words that have twice the
same that I value meaning the first one
and the last one other thing so we have
here other examples were such that every
consecutive that has are different so
it's the same thing but now each time we
are ok so it's the same thing but now we
have a zero which is the absorbing
element of the monorail and whenever we
make the product of tours we carefully
check that the the data value that is
the meeting point are different
otherwise we fall down to the zero
element says there are two values two
consecutive values that are equal right
and otherwise it's well that should not
be that that should be just d square
another nice example is the following
one you give me an integer K
non-negative integer K and you are just
verifying that your word contains
exactly k distinct that I values and
then there the nominal monoid is as
follows you have an absorbing element as
as soon as you have found more than K
values you just go to this element and
otherwise you just construct a set of
the data values that you have seen in
the current word so in this case the
product is just the union of the sets
but sometimes you exceed k and then you
should fall down to 0 right and the more
physics tarts from the letter and say if
you have a letter D then the only value
that you see the D and then and then you
accept the sets only of those orbits
that have support of size K right and
you can make non-example were such that
all that has are distinct for instance
well there is a minimal nominal mono it
for that but it has infinitely many
orbits because essentially if you want
to check in the product of two words if
suddenly you make appear some value that
hip it twice you need to know all the
values of the first word and all the
values of the second one and that's much
too much for an orbit finite thing right
so now we know what are these objects
yes now what are the logics for data
words and here again I did not well that
it's a very well specified in the
literature so here I'm making an I have
this finite Part B which is a B or not I
bet the finite alphabet and we have this
database so we're look slike that and
i'm defining first-order logic with this
tilde operation which is normal
first-order logic where variable with
the range over the positions in this
word we have like all the standard
things of first order but then
you up predicate that we have is X is
equivalent to why and that means the
value at position X and the value at
position why are the same right so this
gives you a logic and if you give it a
worm like that it either accepted or
rejected and the Magnetic second-order
version of it is exactly the same you
take this logic and you add miletic
second order quantity or quantifiers and
variables to it so for instance the
first and last that has are the same in
my word well very easy I say let for all
x and y such that X looks like the first
element and why looks like the last
element X is equivalent to white for
this thing here some data reappears okay
there is execs different from Y such
that X is equal to Y some data appears
an odd number of time then you would use
some melodic second-order qualifiers to
do that so one just one thing you have
to remark in this definition is that
because you never talk explicitly about
a data value you can only talk about
whether what it is to carry the same
data you are invariant under the
permutation if you apply a permutation
of the name and you apply to every
letter if a formula holds before it also
holds after so the objects that you
construct all the ways equivalent so I
mentioned undecidability in fact it goes
very quickly but it's interesting to see
it because yes i will tell you what
rigid I wow i just have 10 minutes left
maybe not know how will that so why is
it undecidable it goes very very easy
let's take this alphabet you have a
finite part with two letters A and B and
an infant part and then we will
interpret graphs in it so a vertex will
be from a maximal interval of positions
that are that all carry the same level
eight and I put an edge between two
vertices if they have they contain one
position that have the same
so for instance here I have a word I've
put in bold those that are the maximal
intervals of A's and the having same
value defines this so I can see it as
being interpreted in this triangle and
it's obvious that like that you would
construct every graph and since first
order is not decidable for on the class
of all finite graphs you is undecidable
so well then what do you do for that so
there is a long story of things so you
can say oh but then i will make a logic
that looks on graph like something that
is decidable like a modern logical new
calculus logic there are some version of
that that are called walking logic but
that's not what I want to do here my
goal is to capture the expressive power
of orbit finite nominal monoids so for
this i require a very specific notion
which is rigid it just before to tell
what what we know this this business of
nominal or between Edmund it was
introduced by McCoy by and check in 2010
under the name of that I'm gonna eat
because you be constructed within from
scratch and what we know is like that
every data language that is recognized
by an orbit finite mono it is definable
in this logic if you are definable in
the first order fragment then you are a
periodic I will not talk about what it
is and and that's the most difficult
part if you are recognizable by an orbit
finite a periodic minute then you are
first order definable so that looks like
that you have things that are all beat
finite monoid and you can intersect them
with a peyote city and what you know is
what you know here is that this part is
exactly the one that is first order
definable into this part to be too weird
well it's a very interesting result but
it sounds like it's not finished yet so
that's that's what we do here I should
give you examples of people that live in
every undies of this
classes I don't know if I'm doing it the
question if you are interested so what
we have here in fact is that for these
two classes we have an exact syntactic
logical equivalent to for defining these
languages what is rigidity rigidity is
so it's a way to guard this equivalence
test so if we allowed to compare any
value X or Y and say do you carry the
same data value you immediately run into
trouble because you define things that
go in every direction and every graph is
definable and nothing is is decidable
anymore so you want to restrict it and
the way you restrict it is by using
rigid guards so imagine you have a
formula Phi of X Y no other free
variables I mean I will tell it after
the time I can tell it right now then
you say that it is rigid if if you see
it as defining an relation on the
position of the word then this relation
is a partial x direction so it's a one
to one partial map if you know X there
is only one why for which it if I can
hold and if you know why there is only
one x for which it can hold so you
assume that it is the case on every
model you can say so example the first X
is the first and why is the last that's
a bit trivial example but indeed it
happens if you know X you know why and
you don't even know need to know X to
know why but the success of relation is
of this form because if you know X you
know who is the successor and if you
know the successor you know who's the
predecessor this one is a bit more it
says X is on a position labeled by an a
why is also in a position level by ona
and and they are on this order and in
the interval there is no other ace so
it's like it's it's a relation that says
I'm on an AI jump to the next day and
and I can go backward in a unique way so
it's also a rigid
right so one complaint that is done
sometime about this work is that is it's
a semantic notion so it turns out that
we can decide it in the process but in
fact we can also enforce it
syntactically and how do we do that
imagine you have a formula Phi of X Y
okay someone tells you it's rigid but
you have no idea why will be whether is
we did on that then you can construct it
formula Phi prime of X Y let's say is
fire okay and furthermore it says if you
take any other x prime that is in
venetian with Y then X prime should be
equal to X and same to two same for y
what does this formula it does something
it wit recognize a subset of the graph
of the radiation defined by five and if
I happens to be rigid then it's exactly
the same set so it's a way to enforce
syntactically to be rigid yes so the Phi
prime is always we did as the point
right so what is rigid first order so
you remember this testing that two
positions carry the same data value well
you only allow it if it is guarded by a
Phi that is rigid and should not contain
any other values right so that's the
definition so I mean this looks good for
existing short quantifier like there
exists x and y that are guarded such
that they are equivalent but if you want
to do it with universal quantifier you
would like to have something if x and y
are equivalent then x is equivalent to Y
for all X yes but in fact this is just
syntactic sugar because Phi of X Y
implies exocrine to why you just take
this previous construction and you add
disjunct with the negation so so this
means you have the two two cases yes
so now in this logic we can pick our
example the first and last value exists
that's because there exists X Y such
that and then x is equal run to Y but
you guarded by first of X and last of y
which is rigid so it's a valid thing
every odd position letters carries the
same value well you define in magnetic
second-order logic which is an odd
position and you can define what it is
to jump on the next odd position and and
then you say every two odd position as
the same value as the next one and then
you have you have explicitly rigidly
linked one valuated odd position with
the two next one there are two lay
consecutive letters that carry the same
value you can also do it just placing
there exists x and y such that relate
that are related by successor and she
can share the same a value but you see
that if you want to do something like
some value appears twice that was so
easy there exists X different from Y and
X is equivalent to Y then it's
impossible to guard it because you have
no clue what is the relation that would
allow you to jump from X to Y okay so
the proof goes in two directions what
what do I want to say exactly in the two
minutes that remain okay this story is
about saying if you want to transform
magnetic second-order logic into monoid
then either you use type if you are of
the compositional family or you use a
closure operation if you are more use
two languages but essentially that's
exactly the same in this context and so
essentially you say if I have my regular
languages i have many closure operation
then i will have one that would
correspond to each of the construction
of my logic so i can combine my logic
into operation and regular languages and
but the problem is that the existential
quantifier makes means the projection so
it supports
and in general if you take the power set
of a no-bid finite set then suddenly
it's not orbit finite anymore so powers
that is not allowed and so here there is
the solution is to make the two to be
careful about how we make this
projection and we have this property of
project ability and this essentially
this says that whenever you want to
project at some point to and well to
remove piece of the information so which
is a projection if you reach the same
orbit then you have to be equal and it
happens that if you have this property
then the power set its infinite but the
elements that you really need they are
orbit finite and and in fact you can
preserve this property so you can
compile you compiled with the standard
algorithm your logic and you just
maintain the information that everything
is projectable so that's one way and the
other way I can how much time you have
take me two minutes just so for the
other way I just want to show you that
it's more complicated than the usual 144
so usually when you have a monad mono it
and you want to make it to formula of ms
so what do you do you say that's very
easy I'm my mono it I can even see it as
a deterministic automaton I use an
existential quantifier I guess the run
and then I check that everything is
consistent done right here that will not
work at all like that and I will try to
convince you in an example you remember
this example it's not the one I wanted
this example that says k value appears
exactly not this one yes i will show you
how you construct it and you will see
that you need to nest guards inside
guards inside guards k times which
essentially rules out any of this simple
construction where you would guess
everything at the beginning and make
local check and so you want to have K
values so the first thing you say is
value 1 XY and value 1 XY is a formula
that tells you in the interval from X to
Y there is exactly one that I value so X
has to be smaller than Y and whenever I
jump to the success so it needs always
be the same data value and now when i do
that i can define an operation successor
one this one would be in something
success or zero and it says something
like that x is beautiful one before why
if i look at things that are in the
interval without the endpoints then it
has only one value but if i look from
here to here it has two values and it
right loop from here to here it has two
values so in some say it's a rigid way
to jump to the next point living in the
inter in the interval something that has
only one that I value right and this is
something which is rigid and now you can
define to have to what it is to birth to
values well you do eggs in fact exactly
the same thing but you jump by longer
steps so you can to define to define two
values you need first to define one
value and use it in a guard and so on so
so so that's that that well you go and
you do the language and that shows that
the
essentially I mean you cannot do for us
for normal languages the question is
where does this induction come from like
this value one because at some point you
have a money then you need to construct
this formula so you need this injection
come from well it comes from the Greens
relation of the nominal Madrid so just
these two say that a good part of this
work is to make a very precise analysis
of how to look the Greens relations in
an orbit finite nominal Madrid that's
like the internal machinery for
understanding how to produce the
formerly and then there is a conclusion
that says exactly all that I said
because I'm late and it has a funny
application which is that if you have an
orbit finite mono in you can see it as
as essentially a letter that represents
the orbit and then topples of variables
and with possibly permutation among
these variables on the photo so
typically for instance you can see this
the set of pairs of two distinct element
you can see it as there's an ordered set
a pair of odd another pair with a group
action saying like x and y are the same
thing like switching x and y is the same
thing and and when one consequence of
this construction is this fact that if
you have a finite ma no heed you can
always see it as the quotient of the
money that has no permutation like that
and which is not an obvious result and
we don't know any other proof of it but
the way we do it is that we construct a
kind of language we construct the
formula we go back to the Madrid and
this permutation stuff has disappeared
so that's that's how it works well so I
think I conclude now this talk and well
again thank you everyone
right hitting not I'd like to thank the
organizers need went and mousses
Alexandra in absentia and the staff of
the Institute and all of you for being
here if you stay around tomorrow then to
disclose a holiday it's veterans day and
safe travels of you but soon thank you